benvenuti alla terza puntata di
temptation highland vip
[Musica]
occupiamoci subito di valeria e patrick
nel villaggio delle fidanzate una
stellare e sportivissima valeria si
lascia convincere dalle belle spagnolo
egan ad un allenamento molto duro dritto
scendi scendi così così salire nei
mammamia cadeau l'ora 10 dieci volti
questura no ma guarda che corpo che cioè
io non ti posso guardare veramente mi
devo distrarre per patrick invece è
tempo di pineto quello che vedrà gli
darà finalmente un forte scossone spero
tutte senti sola se una tigre sassola tu
non sei sola perché adesso stai con me
tu merita un uomo che prenda posizioni
la prendiamo la prendiamo di un uomo che
ti se fa prendere nel modo giusto
sei molto maturo per la torta
complimenti perché li ha portato qua per
farmi vedere sta roba qua io non voglio
una bambina se lei ha voluto fare questo
percorso per farmi vedere sta roba qua
bene brava complimenti
baci stellari a di stellari lasciamo il
povero patrick ha i suoi pensieri e
occupiamoci invece di andrea z e la sua
fidanzata alessandra lui fa un lavoro
che non gli piace dice che si sente
inutile nella sua azienda
solo che titolare il padrino le cambia
niente a dargli lo stipendio
reagan a sputtanata generale dice che mi
mamma rompe sempre [ __ ] che sono
viziato che lo faccio mai nulla
dopo due settimane si è svegliata e
arrivato il momento del falò delle
fidanzate fidanzate benvenuti a un altro
falò valeria vorrei incominciare da te
perché ho un filmato per te finalmente
il problema di valeria e che lei ha dei
difetti questi difetti sono il fatto che
lei non sappia stare da sola che abbia
sempre bisogno una persona accanto
capito cioè io ho il mio lavoro non
posso farmi stipendiare da lei se lei ha
bisogno di un'assistente si prendono
assistente finita lì io non voglio fare
il suo assistente
beh sì ma quello che mi dispiace che lui
non ha capito niente
mi sembra un discorso molto riduttivo
lui parla solo del personaggio dal mio
lavoro non ha capito che la nostra
relazione si deve basare su dei
sentimenti io ho bisogno di sentirmi
amata
non lo so se fate l'ex sa cos'è l'amore
appena arrivata nel villaggio delle
fidanzate valeria è furiosa con coguaro
e si sfoga con i suoi compagni di
viaggio
no un [ __ ] guarda proprio un cretino
falso come giuda si merita delle corna
guarda che pare proprio un cretino
cretino cretino cretino cretino con un
14 cv e il momento del risveglio e del
villaggio dei fidanzati fin dal primo
mattino il re leone sossio reagisce così
[Musica]
occupiamoci ora di una coppia molto
amata di tempe shaun island dic
sto parlando del menu fa e jordan fate
bene attenzione perché siamo di fronte a
una svolta
giordano sta per affrontare il suo falò
dopo aver visto nilufar vicinissima al
singoli nicolo ferro giordano che ho
visto molto taciturno in questi giorni
molto riflessivo sì perché ho capito che
ios è entrato qua per risolvere i
problemi le invece sarà distrugge tutto
per la seconda volta giordano ho filmato
per te immaginiamo
secondo me è una coppia che non durerà a
quella di nilo fare giordano e tu pensi
che di lifar piaccio un po voi siete
perfetti insieme ma gliel'ho detto anche
a nilufar quando scelto giordano ci sono
rimasto troppo male poi me ne sono fatto
una ragione
però quando ci siamo ritrovati qua cioè
era come se non avesse mai scelto
giordano poi le ricerca cioè circa le
mie attenzioni dei b questa è la canzone
della prima esterna nostra basta basta
perché ho sentito troppo ho visto troppo
e mi sento preso per il culo
voglio un parole confronto immediato se
non me ne vado stasera stessa
quindi vuoi falò di confronto anticipato
questa sera si simo ora subito se non me
ne vado stasera stessa
vediamo quello che riusciamo a fare
giordano ragazzi devo parlare un attimo
con nilufar nilufar giordano ha chiesto
un falò di confronto immediato con tris
avendo un importo io ti aspetto al falò
cosa ha visto cosa ho visto cosa ho
visto cosa ho visto che fermi fermi
fermi fermi cosa ha visto cosa ha visto
perché immediato perché immediato
allora giordano sono andata al villaggio
ho parlato con i luf ar e gli ho detto
che tu vuoi il confronto immediato
quindi aspettiamo insieme e vediamo se
lei accetterà o meno di venire al
confronto
ma che è normale tutta sta attesa non ci
sto capendo niente a due all'ora o non
c'ho capito un cazzo io fino ad ora ho
mai solo preso per il culo che cosa
avresti visto in coerenza se è entrata
qui dentro estratti angelo ho visto
tutti i giorni di spensieratezza
assoluta l'ultima cosa che dovevi fare
la parla con nicolò l'ultima mi fa
parlammo secondo gli hanno preso tutti
per il culo perché non facciamo altro
che parlare di te della tua schiena va a
me parla a tutti questi atteggiamenti
che c'è come te li devi raramente vi fa
parla sei innamorato snia ha risposto
fini mi pare che le dimostrazioni ce ne
ha avute anche dante io ho capito tutto
e notevole lettere che avevo scritto ma
che ne parli con i colori nostri
giordano giordano che giordano che dopo
tutto quello che è successo sai che cosa
che dovevi amicolo ferrari è mattia fa
due passi da un'altra parte
e invece no sulla panchina parlare con
lui nicolò portami un deca ma un legale
crema che ti fai porta non gli posso
chiedere un caffè
no nicolò non giro poi chiede come non
c'è poi tanta perfect la canzone della
prima esterna nostra o non la cantino la
canti parlavo solo ed esclusivamente
ride nel nostro rapporto solo di questo
le diceva sai quante cose abbiamo in
comune
e sai cosa gli ho detto l'amore non
funziona così
io me ne faccio niente una persona vuole
ma io voglio diversa la questione di con
la ferrari è stata chiusa 15 di maggio
io sono sicurissimo i miei sentimenti e
tutte le persone che conosco lo so
ok giordano ti faccio io una domanda tu
sei innamorato di me lo fa se io sono
passato sopra una roba del genere è un
motivo ci sta io ti ho chiesto subito è
il faro del confronto motivo cessa e non
mi guarda cosa faccia che lo sai che
sono innamorato di te stupida o ce
l'abbiamo fatta a far dire ti amo a
giordano
ecco allora io ho la domanda di rito
giordano vuoi uscire da solo o con milu
far ero quasi convinto di uscire da solo
non ci riesce
amore mio grande eco l'amore è bello se
litigarello solo un po però è buona
fortuna ragazzi per nilufar e giordano
il viaggio nei sentimenti termina qui
lasciano tentation highland vip più
consapevoli e più sicuri del loro amore
nel villaggio delle fidanzate c'è
qualcuno che piange sto parlando del
single niccolò ferrari che ancora una
volta sperava di far breccia nel cuore
della bella di luca a consolarlo ci
pensa la nostra valeria non riuscì più
di quelli sbagliati ma ti sei visto che
bello che sai cioè non ti manca
veramente niente ti manca solo il
mantello è il cavallo bianco per essere
un principe azzurro fortunata beata
chiti sana con traguardo
siamo giunti al termine della terza
puntata
la prossima sarà l'ultima tappa del
nostro viaggio nei sentimenti
se non l'avete ancora fatto iscrivetevi
al canale e lasciateli un bel live
seguitemi su tutti gli altri social per
rimanere sempre aggiornati e per vedere
tante altre imitazioni ma soprattutto
ricordate di spiare il vostro amore ma
ascoltare sempre sempre sempre il vostro
cuore
alla prossima puntata